Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Je vous propose de parler de consentement.
Pour moi, pendant très longtemps,
ce mot n’existait pas dans ma vie.
Quand j’ai commencé à avoir
des rapports sexuels,
je ne le connaissais pas.
Je ne le trouvais pas non plus
dans les livres que je lisais sur le sexe.
Je m’appelle Olympe De Gê
et j’ai commencé à apprendre
le consentement
quand j’ai décidé de faire du porno.
On est en 2016,
j’ai 33 ans.
Et je veux réaliser des films qui montrent
des corps de plein de formes différentes,
qui montrent des pratiques sexuelles
qui font du bien aux femmes,
qui montrent de la cyprine,
qui montre des émotions.
Bref, je veux réaliser des films
qui montrent du beau sexe.
Parce que je veux bien pouvoir
diriger mes futurs performeurs,
je décide que je vais
commencer par tourner,
moi, avec mon corps dans un porno.
Une semaine avant le jour J,
la réalisatrice m’invite
à rencontrer mon co-performeur.
On va l’appeler Siegfried.
On boit un thé tous les trois
et Siegfried me demande :
« Alors, c’est quoi tes limites ? ».
Moi, à ce moment là de ma vie,
je n’en n’ai aucune idée.
À 33 ans, je n’ai jamais réfléchi
posément à ce que j’aimais
et puis, surtout,
à ce que je n’aimais pas dans le sexe.
J’ai beaucoup plus réfléchi
à comment être un bon coup.
Avec Siegfried, on se met d’accord
sur une scène qui me fait envie.
Puis, le tournage se passe très bien.
Quelques mois passent et ça y est,
je réalise enfin mon premier
court-métrage pornographique.
Je suis pleine d'idéaux.
Je veux faire du porno éthique
où tout est discuté, tout est consenti.
Je serai mon actrice principale
et puis, mon co-performeur
sera de nouveau Siegfried.
Je me fais plaisir
je mets en scène
un fantasme de longue date.
Je conduis une grosse moto
au lever du jour,
quand soudain,
j’aperçois un moto-stoppeur.
Je m'arrête.
On sympathise
et on sympathise à tel point
qu’il enlève tous ses vêtements
et qu’il monte derrière moi, tout nu.
(Rires)
Et puis, je le ramène.
Vous voyez la suite.
On veut tourner cette scène
dans des rues désertes.
On ne veut pas exposer
Siegfried aux regards.
Donc, on se lève à 3h du matin.
Mais pas de bol, les soucis
techniques se succèdent.
Et le temps qu’on arrive au moment
où Siegfried monte derrière moi
sur la moto,
il est 7h, il y a pas mal de trafic.
(Rires)
On tourne la scène,
on boucle le film, tout va bien.
Un an plus tard, le film est sorti.
Il est passé en festival.
Je recontacte Siegfried pour
lui proposer un nouveau projet.
Et là, Siegfried me répond :
« Non ».
Il me répond qu’il ne
retravaillera jamais avec moi.
Il m’explique que son consentement
n’a pas été respecté
lors du tournage de la scène à moto.
Il m’explique qu’il était d’accord
pour tourner nu dans les rues
mais il ne voulait pas de monde autour.
Wow !
C'est vrai.
Il me l'avait dit.
Et moi, quand on s’est retrouvés
sur la moto, entourés de voitures,
je me suis dit :
« Si Siegfried ne me dit rien.
C’est que finalement c’est ok. »
Et j’avoue qu’à ce moment-là,
je suis focus sur l’objectif
de mettre la scène dans la boîte.
À ce moment-là,
ça se bouscule dans ma tête,
j’ai une réaction défensive.
Je me dis : « Bon ok, mais attends,
pourquoi il ne me l’a pas dit y a un an ?
Pourquoi il me le dit maintenant ?
Qu’est-ce qu’il me veut ? ».
Je réfléchis, je me dis :
« Mais est-ce qu’à l’époque,
il aurait pu se sentir sous-pression ? ».
Ces questions-là , je me les pose
pour la première fois en 2017,
grâce à Siegfried qui a eu le courage
de me dire les choses en face.
Pourtant, ça fait des années
que je fais des tournages,
alors pourquoi je ne m’interroge
que maintenant ?
Peut-être parce que,
comme vous j’imagine,
je n’ai pas grandi dans
une culture du consentement.
J’ai plutôt grandi dans une culture
du dépassement de soi,
où il faut sans cesse dépasser ses limites
si on veut arriver
à quelque chose dans la vie.
Une culture où le sacrifice de la santé,
de la vie perso ou l’épuisement même
sont valorisés.
Comme vous peut-être,
j’ai beaucoup plus appris
à endurer que poser des limites.
J’ai beaucoup plus appris
à m’imposer qu’à respecter.
Du coup, à 33 ans,
sur le sujet du consentement,
qu’il s’agisse du mien
ou de celui des autres,
je débarque.
Comme je ne sais pas écouter mes limites,
je ne sais pas écouter les autres.
J'ai présenté mes excuses à Siegfried.
Il ne les a pas acceptées.
C’est pas super confortable
de vous raconter ça,
mais si je le fais,
c’est parce que je suis
vraiment convaincue
que parler de nos erreurs pourrait
nous permettre d’avancer collectivement.
Et heureusement,
le consentement, ça s’apprend.
Ça se pratique.
Le consentement, c'est une gymnastique.
Plus on s’exerce,
plus on apprend à connaître son corps,
à se connaître,
plus on gagne en force
et plus on gagne en souplesse.
Apprendre à se connaître,
c’est d’abord apprendre à s’écouter.
Est-ce que ça vous arrive quand
quelqu’un attend quelque chose de vous,
d’avoir cette petite voix
dans votre tête qui vous dit :
« Ouais mais non, je ne le sens pas ».
Je ne sais pas pour vous
mais j’ai souvent été hyper paternaliste
avec cette petite voix.
Je lui disais : « Mais si vas-y,
l’envie va venir en s’y mettant.
Puis après, ce sera fait ».
Faire ça, c’est un peu comme soulever
de la fonte avec un poignet foulé.
C'est une connerie.
Quand notre petite voix nous dit :
« Ça ne va pas, je ne le sens pas ».
On la croit et on arrête.
La force.
Plus on pratique
la gymnastique du consentement,
plus on gagne une force
et cette force, c’est l’assertivité.
Peu à peu, on va muscler
notre capacité  à affirmer nos limites
sans avoir peur de froisser l’autre.
Donc, face à cette personne
qui attend quelque chose de nous,
on dit tout simplement :
« Je préfère arrêter.
Je sens que je n’ai pas envie.
Je sens que je n’ai plus envie ».
Apprendre à se connaître
et muscler son assertivité,
c’est une même face du consentement,
c’est la face qui concerne nos limites.
La souplesse, c’est l’autre face,
celle qui concerne les limites des autres.
Cette souplesse consiste
à accueillir l’assertivité des autres.
Quand on nous dit « non »
ou alors « ouais mais... »,
on ne se fait pas un claquage,
on répond tout en souplesse :
« Ok, Je l’entends,
qu’est-ce que tu veux
faire à la place ? ».
Deux ans après le non de Siegfried,
je tourne mon premier long-métrage.
Cette fois, je reste derrière la caméra
et je me dis : « Tu as une mission.
Placer le consentement au cœur du projet,
le montrer à l’écran
et l’appliquer tout au long
du processus de fabrication du film ».
Alors, je déploie plusieurs actions.
Pour que les performeurs sachent
ce à quoi ils et elles vont consentir,
j’écris des scènes de sexe en détail,
avec des didascalies, avec des schémas.
Pour structurer la conversation
autour des limites,
je propose un questionnaire
avec des questions du genre :
« C’est ok,
utiliser la salive comme lubrifiant ? ».
« Est-ce que c’est ok la tienne,
celle de l’autre ? ».
Il y a deux pages comme ça.
J’embauche une coordinatrice d’intimité.
Je propose de payer les cachets
avant de tourner les scènes.
Et pendant que je fais tout ça,
il y a une vague de témoignages
qui inonde les réseaux sociaux.
#payetongyneco.
#stopauxviolencesgynécologiques.
Et là, ça me frappe.
Entre un tournage de porno
et une consultation de gynéco,
il y a des points communs.
Dans les deux cas, il y a au centre,
une personne qui expose son sexe
dans un environnement
qu’elle ne connaît pas
et face à elle,
il y a une ou plusieurs
personnes habillées,
en position de savoir
et qui dictent le déroulement des choses.
Dans les deux cas,
le performeur qui enlève
son tee-shirt sur le bord de la route
ou la patiente qui se déshabille
avant l’examen,
on se dit que ces deux personnes
savent ce qui va se passer ensuite.
On se dit qu'elles ont consenti
implicitement à tout ce qui va suivre.
Et du coup, on ne vérifie pas
régulièrement si ça va.
Avec ce parallèle un peu inattendu
entre monde médical et monde du X,
je comprends un nouveau
paramètre du consentement.
C'est l'asymétrie de la relation.
Il y a plein de situations
où on n’est pas d’égal à égal.
Il y a une personne
qui va être très à l’aise
parce qu’elle a plus d’informations,
elle a plus d’expérience,
elle a plus de reconnaissance.
Et il y a une personne en face
qui peut-être lui fait confiance,
l’admire, est impressionnée.
Et cette personne-là, elle risque
d’avoir plus de mal à dire non.
Ces relations asymétriques sont partout.
Alors, il y a le soignant-soigné
mais il y a aussi employeur-employé,
manager-managé, enseignant-étudiant,
adulte-enfant,
attachés émotionnellement,
détachés émotionnellement?
38 ans-18 ans, conducteur-passager, etc.
Et dans une relation asymétrique,
c’est la personne qui est en position
de savoir, de pouvoir, d’expérience,
d’autorité,
qui a la responsabilité d’être proactive
et de demander encore et encore :
« Est-ce que ça va ? Vous êtes d’accord ?
Comment vous vous sentez ? On y va ? ».
Pour mieux comprendre
comment assurer le consentement
dans les situations asymétriques,
je décide de travailler
sur la relation soignant-soigné.
Pendant deux ans,
je bosse avec un professeur de médecine
et j’observe plein
de services hospitaliers,
maternité, réanimation,
SAMU, pédopsychiatrie.
Et là, mon acharnement finit par payer,
je comprends encore quelque chose
de nouveau sur le consentement
grâce aux professionnels de santé.
Les soignants et les soignantes
qui ont pratiqué la gymnastique
du consentement,
consultation après consultation,
ont saisit quelque chose de crucial.
Ils savent accueillir le non
de leur patient comme un cadeau.
Quand on refuse de monter sur la balance,
de se déshabiller, d’être examiné,
notre non peut soit crisper la relation
avec un médecin qui va nous dire :
« Je peux rien faire pour vous ».
Soit au contraire,
aiguiller cette relation
vers de nouvelles idées,
un nouveau dialogue.
On peut essayer de comprendre ce non,
on peut poser des questions.
On va peut-être apprendre qu’il y a eu
un historique de violence ou un trauma.
Ces informations vont venir
enrichir la relation de soin.
Et ça, c’est un cadeau
qui est vraiment utile et précieux
pour les soignants et les soignantes.
Ce travail est devenu
une unité d’enseignement
pour les étudiants en médecine
de la Sorbonne.
C’est aussi devenu un podcast
mais surtout, ça a eu un impact
dans ma vie personnelle.
Parce que je me suis dit que moi aussi,
j’avais envie de mieux connaître
les personnes autour de moi,
que moi aussi,
j’avais envie qu’on me dise non.
Alors, je me suis mise
à poser plein de questions.
Quand je retrouve des amis :
« On se fait la bise ou pas ? »,
« C’est ok si je te parle
d’un sujet un peu difficile »;
Avec les enfants :
« Tu es d’accord pour que
je t’enlève ton haut de pyjama ? ».
Au travail aussi,
je continue de pratiquer :
« Est-ce qu’on peut se tutoyer ? »,
« Je peux t’appeler
ou tu préfères les emails, les sms ? ».
Au début, je trouvais
qu’on ne me disait pas beaucoup non.
J’étais un peu déçue.
Et puis, peu à peu, j’ai vu,
la personne être silencieuse,
hésiter, détourner le regard,
son visage se crisper.
En fait, elle me disait non.
Plus on pratique
la gymnastique du consentement,
plus on apprend à reconnaître
le non chez les autres
mais aussi chez soi-même.
Les deux faces du consentement.
Reconnaître le consentement,
ça profite à tout le monde.
Le non permet de nous réajuster ensemble
pour être de même sentiment.
Parce que c’est ça,
l’étymologie de consentir,
« Consensus », être de même sentiment.
S’il y a un endroit où j’aime
être de même sentiment,
c’est dans ma vie intime et sexuelle.
Là aussi, je pratique
ma gymnastique du consentement
et je pose des questions.
Je pose des questions avant le sexe,
je pose des questions pendant le sexe.
Ça peut surprendre.
J’ai remarqué,
que ce soit dans les films
ou avec mes partenaires,
qu’il y a une sorte
de convention sexuelle.
Quand on commence
à faire l’amour, on se tait.
Les mots n’ont plus leur place,
ils deviennent tue-l’amour.
Alors, on respire très fort.
On espère que nos corps vont réussir
à communiquer de façon télépathique,
que le désir va nous faire
entrer en communion.
C’est beau, hein ?
En théorie.
Mais en pratique,
pour éviter les malentendus
et les rapports sexuels mal vécus,
je trouve que ce n’est pas forcément
ce qu’il y a de plus efficace.
Donc, au lieu de passer l’acte à regarder
mes partenaires dans le blanc des yeux,
je trouve plus simple
et plus naturel de m’intéresser à eux.
« Comment tu te sens ?
Est ce que ça, ça fait du bien ?
Et, folie, je me suis même mise
à dire ce dont j’avais envie,
au lieu d’espérer
qu’ils allaient tout deviner.
Alors, je dis :
« Ça te dis si on fait ci ou ça »
ou alors : « Laisse-moi te guider ».
Le consentement n’est pas
un contrat à signer,
ce n’est pas une corvée.
C’est une dynamique
qui fait naître le désir,
qui le fait monter,
qui nous permet de nous connecter.
Poser des mots sur nos corps,
sur nos sexes, sur nos envies,
c’est érotique.
Le consentement, c'est sexy.
Dire : « Oui, j’aime ça,
je veux ça », c’est sexy.
Dire non, c'est sexy aussi.
On peut dire non avec des mots
mais on peut aussi dire
non avec un silence
ou bien avec le corps.
Quand on dit non,
que ce soit au lit
ou dans la vie de tous les jours,
on ne casse pas l’ambiance.
On se fait un beau cadeau
à nous-mêmes et aux autres.
On s'offre la possibilité de relations
plus égalitaires, plus saines.
Alors, il y a plein de situations où on a
vraiment très envie qu’on nous dise oui
mais c’est notre responsabilité de laisser
une chance à l’autre de pouvoir dire non.
Et ça d’autant plus quand on est
en situation de pouvoir, de savoir,
d’expérience, d’autorité.
Le consentement,
c’est vraiment notre mission.
Et c'est vraiment pas mission impossible.
Ça prend combien temps de demander :
« Vous êtes d’accord ?,
Est-ce que ça va ? »,
« Comment vous vous sentez ? ».
C’est vrai que ces questions, au début,
elles ne semblent pas très naturelles.
C’est vrai qu’on ne nous dit pas
toujours non explicitement
qu’il faut parfois réussir
à le reconnaître ce non,
à le déceler.
Mais je vous promets qu’en pratiquant
le consentement un peu tous les jours,
comme une gymnastique,
vous allez muscler votre assertivité.
Vous allez assouplir votre empathie
et vous allez développer
un super-pouvoir relationnel.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)